there's these deadly viruses they're not
very transmissible
ebola rabies and then there's these less
deadly viruses that are very
transmissible
um
like uh
like covid is i guess kind of borderline
but
uh why isn't there
super transmissible super deadly viruses
i think if you compare stars one and two
you get
somewhat of an answer right sars one was
more deadly
in fact
over half of the time
when people were infected they ended up
in the hospital because they were that
sick
and then
the peak of virus shedding from them
happened long after they went in the
hospital so it's easy to contain
uh the infection when you're in a
hospital right
there was not much
pre-symptomatic or asymptomatic
shedding with sars1 and shedding means
you you're in you become infectious so
in a respiratory virus you're you inhale
the droplets with virus and they
reproduce in your upper respiratory
tract what we call the nasopharynx right
the nose and going back to that little
cavity just above your mouth
so virus reproduces really well and then
as you talk and sneeze and cough you
expel droplets and then those are
inhaled by other people and then they
reproduce and
for sars two we now know there's a lot
of reproduction just before you feel
anything if at all so there's a lot of
shedding and transmission before you get
symptomatic and many people don't ever
get symptomatic right so they spread
really easily so that explains why some
viruses can transmit a lot better than
others and if one happens to knock you
out
then you're never going to transmit
because you're in the hospital like
sorrows one but why can't you have both
why can't you just wait a while before
he knocks you out but one knocks you out
it really kills you that's that is a
philosophical question right because
we could talk about why we haven't
observed it i mean one one issue is that
if you uh
if you're killed too quickly by a highly
lethal virus
you're not going to transmit it very
well right so ebola can kill you quite
rapidly
and most of the transmission occurs
when people are being cared for at home
or in hospitals the doctors and nurses
get virus but people walking around
you're not walking around when you have
ebola you're too sick
you know you have black bloody diarrhea
you're vomiting you're
you're bleeding from your skin and
mucous membranes you're not walking
around not going to parties so
i think that's part of it that if if the
infection is too lethal you're simply
not a good transmitter and i think
transmission
is probably one of the most powerful
selection
forces for viruses because of ours
always has to have find a new host if it
doesn't
it's a startup that fails right if it
doesn't find a new host it's gone and so
anything that makes the virus transmit
better
is going to help it and if killing you
being less lethal is part of that that
works too so there's a strong selection
pressure against being lethal i think
there's a strong selection
pressure against being lethal and
being more transmissible
those two
seem to work in opposite ways and now we
don't have a lot of data to support this
this is kind of a
thought
experiment but there is one
experiment done in australia
many years ago i don't know if you know
this but in the 1800s the hunters in
australia imported a rabbit from europe
so they could hunt it
because the native rabbit in australia
was too fast for them they couldn't
shoot them so they brought in this
european rabbit
and they they reproduced out of control
within a couple of years they were
everywhere millions of rabbits and all
the watering holes
and now they had a problem so they
decided to use a virus to get rid of
these excess rabbits
and they used a virus a pox virus called
mixoma virus which is a natural virus of
a different kind of rabbit
but for these european rabbits it was
quite lethal and it's spread by
mosquitoes so they said okay let's let's
uh release this virus and the first year
99.2 percent of the rabbits were killed
but that point eight percent that were
left
had some form of resistance they were
variants you know every organism not
just viruses makes mutants and there
were some variants of the rabbits that
could survive infection and then in
subsequent years the virus became less
lethal and then
the mosquitoes had a better shot of
transmitting it from one rabbit to
another if the rabbit lived longer
that's the selection probably and so in
the end the rabbits lived on the virus
was there it evolved to be more
transmissible and less
uh
lethal so that is amazing that's the
only data that's amazing
it is it is if you take the time to
look at it and see what's happened it is
amazing it's also humbling that it just
makes you realize humans are just a
small part of the picture of course
and we're wrecking it aren't we
well i mean that's that
we're not really
i mean viruses are wrecking it some way
it's part of this we're not really
wrecking anything it's all part of it
but you know when
the ways that human exists encourages
viruses to infect us right when we were
hunter-gatherers living in bands of 100
people very few viruses because it was
hard for the virus to go from one band
to another and perhaps a hunter would
one of these humans would get an animal
and bring a virus at the camp and some
people would die but it would never
spread
to another and then when we started to
congregate in cities we figured out
agriculture and so forth and how to
harvest animals then we could get bigger
and bigger populations and the viruses
went crazy and they went from animals to
us so measles went from cows to humans
when humans learned to domesticate cows
and and started gathering in big cities
yeah but now that humans are able to
communicate and travel globally
the viruses become more and more
dangerous transmissible
thereby if you look at earth as an
organism thereby pushing humans to be
more innovative
create alpha fold two and three and four
and five create better systems and
eventually there's rockets that keep
flying from earth and eventually
uh virus is becoming super dangerous and
threatening all of human civilization
will force it to become a
multi-planetary species and this
organism starts expanding so i think
it's a feature not a bug i don't know
um well i think that we have
our early probably the most of the when
we're studying viruses since 1900 right
most of that time was because of
diseases they caused the first viruses
discovered yellow fever
virus smallpox
poliovirus
influenza virus
those were all because people got sick
and they said oh look this is a virus
that's associated with it and so we got
good at learning how to take care of
these infections making vaccines and so
forth over the years and it's only in
the last 20 years that we recognize that
there are more viruses out there that
are far more interesting perhaps but
we've learned how to deal with the bad
ones for sure
you